I have been on a mortal kombat bender
for the past few days now girl I i I've
lost weight it's a real thing I don't
know if that's a good thing it's
probably not a good thing to feel like
I'm 11 years old again it ain't a bad
thing
Mortal Kombat X that's my epic X so
Mortal Kombat X is out upon us and among
us I've been looking forward to this for
a long time because I am a life long
Mortal Kombat fan I love the last Mortal
Kombat I loved injustice I love what
NetherRealm Studios has been doing some
Mortal Kombat X had a lot to live up to
oh my god this games fun this game nice
a lot going for it first of all I might
talk about the story in a fighting game
usually people feel like that doesn't
matter how is the fighting and I'll get
to the fighting but the story is really
good and worth talking about it's a
fighting game with no stories just your
fighting and that's that Mortal Kombat
has always been thick with lore and
story and this story takes it to the
next level it actually flushes out
characters you see the characters
involved cuz the first part of the story
takes place a couple years after the
events of the last Mortal Kombat then it
jumps 20 years and you see characters
grow and evolve and you're like oh my
god there are layers to Johnny Cage it's
so cinematic it's baffling you look at
it you're like I'm playing a movie
rather you watch a movie and then you
fight the matches and in that there are
a lot of new characters that are
offspring or protegees of the old
characters from Mortal Kombat that we
all knew Cassie cage is the daughter of
Johnny Cage and Sonya Blade Jackie
brings his Jax's daughter Takeda is Ken
she's son he's been trained by scorpion
right there I'm like oh they're gonna
hand it down to new generation I don't
know if I'm gonna want that but the
characters are actually really good I'm
Cassie cage it's one of the best Mortal
Kombat characters I've seen in a long
time she's an instant fan favorite right
there and has one of my favorite
fatalities I have ever seen it's called
selfie if you can see it see it if you
can do it do it if you want to YouTube
it YouTube it point is it's awesome and
the character among the characters shows
when you have two characters going up
against each other and their intros are
specific to the character they're going
up against example if Molina goes up
against Johnny Cage Johnny Cage is like
hey bloody face they just cracks me up I
was like I love that kind of personality
so one of the mechanics this game
implements is fighting styles are three
different fighting styles among the
characters I got really freaked out and
I heard that example Raiden only has his
iconic teleport and one of the fighting
styles I was like why would I use any of
the other two fighting styles if I want
ratings teleport which I will absolutely
want
but in the three different fighting
styles if they take something away from
one fighting style rest assured they
replace it and give you more than enough
to work with the first I was using
Raiden's fighting style with the
teleport now I don't even touch it I use
Thunder God because it's awesome he's so
overpowered as lightning power is so
good it just mixes really well when you
master a character look I'm so good with
his characters like no you're good with
one third of that character try the
other fighting styles you know you're
gonna go online someone's gonna use the
character you know you're like I know
how to fight them he's gonna do [ __ ]
that you've never seen before and you're
gonna be like wait wait what is that how
do I do I need to learn how to do that
and so you ultimately just relearn the
character that's fun to do however I
have yet to run across stage fatality so
I'm gonna go ahead and say stage
fatalities are not in this game which is
a bummer that is an iconic staple of
Mortal Kombat Pitts stage fatalities we
all love them we want to see them but
again with the concept that if this game
takes something away they give you a lot
more in return stage fatalities are gone
but you do have brutality each character
has six brutalities six different ways
on top of the two fatalities they
already have to kill somebody so yeah
you don't have stage fatalities don't
worry you have six other ways on top of
your two fatalities to dispatch people
so really you don't miss the stage
fatalities at all brutalities are so
gratifying ultimately it's you have to
do these certain logistics within the
match and then you do a certain special
move and do something while you're doing
this special move and if it's the last
hit hits somebody like pop off their
head or blow up their body I'll do
something cool you know online when you
do a brutality to someone someone's
taking their controller just rage
quitting on that [ __ ] at their TV their
other mom a new plasma so shinnok is the
big baddie in this game and what I love
about another realm Studios guys if
you're watching I love you for this you
listen to your fans I mean holy [ __ ]
Shao Kahn in the last Mortal Kombat game
was the cheapest piece of [ __ ] I have
ever fought in a fighting game so the
NetherRealm Studios comes out with
injustice Superman is the main bad guy
in that game but he's not like some big
super boss with a crazy shield he
ultimately fights like the character
because he's playable in the game he
fights like a character who fights just
fights like someone online who's really
good but he is completely beatable
because he fights within the rule this
game shinnok is more or less the same
way until he gets to his second form and
then he's an [ __ ] not as bad as shao
kombis teehee spams that chest fireball
thing bag is pretty dumb but again he's
still beatable i have yet to get as
frustrated as people get when they have
brutalities done to them online so
that's good shinnok looks like a badass
I saw him in the character select screen
I'm like that
just looks awesome he looks like a guy
all the characters like when you're
selecting them they walk up and he's all
like says his nose up at people like
yeah I know that as I'm a god [ __ ] so
far online Fighting's pretty fun I hold
my own better and Mortal Kombat X than I
did the last Mortal Kombat game maybe
I'm being chiseled on Mortal Kombat
Mortal Kombat X and injustice benders
all I know is it's more fun for me to
fight people online than it was the
other Mortal Kombat game and I think
it's because the game is more accessible
but that's not to say it's dumbed down
to actually very intricate it's more
involved than the other Mortal Kombat
game and injustice but I don't feel it
alienate people if you know the basic
mechanics of Mortal Kombat and injustice
you're gonna jump right into this game
and have a good time with it and you'll
have more than enough to fill your plate
and Entertain You with the last Mortal
Kombat game I had already unlocked the
entire crypt at the last game this game
I'm the gripped is so huge I thought it
wasn't gonna like because like this 3d
experience you're like walking through
the crypt in first-person I was like
that's just gonna irritate me come on
man I don't want to do this we'll give
me the overhead view thing let me unlock
[ __ ] the exploratory aspect of it's
actually a lot of fun you gotta find
items unlock secret compartments a lot
of stuff to finding the Crypt is
actually the least wasteful crypt I've
ever seen a lot of times in the crypt
there's a lot of fun stuff you know fan
art kind of scene set pictures that's
all fine and dandy but let's face it
we're here to unlock the costumes in the
fatalities and that just speaks to the
fact there's so much stuff in this game
I have unlocked a lot of costumes a lot
of fatalities a lot of brutality some
other stuff too but the point is the
vast majority of things I've unlocked in
this game are all really good more than
the other Mortal Kombat games so Plus on
the Crypt this game also has factions
there are a few factions you can choose
from all pertaining to Mortal Kombat
Lord you get faction points and you see
online like how people in the faction to
do is I owe people in this faction kick
more ass and people in this faction so
you want to like kick a lot of ass and
get your faction points up so you can be
like hey the faction I'm in is actually
good Mortal Kombat at this point has hit
the stride I've always wanted it to hit
where it's like there's not two
characters that are good and then
everyone else sucked you want to get
good with a character you practice with
that character enough and rest assured
you will be good with that character
that's how a fighting game should be you
have to wanting something characters in
the game you want 20-something
characters to be good if someone applies
themselves and actually practices with
the character I do wish there was a
challenge tower in this game you know
like the 300 challenges from the last
Mortal Kombat games just kept me
entertained for a long time however they
do have living towers new towers and new
challenges come all the time I detain
characters you fight and there are
challenges among
at that point I feel like that's going
to be redundant I want like every
challenge in there to be a challenge
like the challenge tower you want to
keep changing it up that's awesome but
ultimately I just feel like I'm fighting
another tower and then once in a while
there are little logistics like with
every other fight or so it's like land
three jump kicks and win but that's not
as hard as the last challenge tower I
would like to see a new challenge every
I don't know week or so it's like five
to ten challenges so here you go boom
that's hard [ __ ] do that guys in the end
Mortal Kombat X had a lot to live up to
I was really looking forward to this
game and it just didn't disappoint me
fighting online is fun fighting in the
game is fun there's enough to keep you
entertained for a very long time I kind
of got a wait around for a bit and see
how this faction thing works out I hope
it's as cool as NetherRealm Studios
thinks it's going to be in the end if
everyone's like alright we're all going
to be Lin quakes Lin Kuei is the coolest
faction around then it got into gates
the point of a faction war really Mortal
Kombat X is absurdly entertaining a lot
of fun the fatalities are disgusting
that's the great thing about next-gen
technology some of these fatalities are
really simple there's a dude who takes a
six-shooter and just shoot someone in
the chest but it looks so real you're
like oh that's disturbingly gross and
that's just one of the many brutally
wonderful fatalities in this game
because Mortal Kombat X is awesome
tacular
all right now I got to go play Mortal
Kombat and lose more weight because I'm
going to go on a bender again be healthy
when you're gaming but do as I say not
as I do right guys a Mortal Kombat X
have you played it what did you think
about it what's your favorite and least
favorite fatalities in the franchise
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more